- That's what I'm talkin' about
my, my.
(gulps)
- What's the matter with you,
Milk?
- Ay, we been homies for a cool
minute.
Ain't it time y'all let me say
it?
- Come on, my dude.
We can't just let you say it.
That word is sacred.
- I'll do whatever y'all
want if y'all let me say it.
Anything, just name it.
- I'mma need all your lunches
for the rest of the school
year and I'm takin' your
main boo for the weekend.
- Done.
You might wanna scrub all
dem holes out first, though,
with sanitizer.
- You gone get it, girl.
Believe that.
- I wanna see that pic
of your mom's melons.
- Done.
(pleasurable moaning)
- Well, I guess you could say it
now.
- Fine.
But just this one time.
- All, hells yeah.
(sniffling) I've been waiting
my whole life for this.
- Ready, on three.
One, two, three.
- Legend!
What?
Y'all thought I was finna say.
(bleeping)
00:00:50,676 --> 00:00:00,000
(slapping and grunting)